This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropic Berry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit, and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details of McDonald's.cai at participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec. Hey, this is Hayes, Davenport, and Sean Clements.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。全新的红牛龙莓和热带莓能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市，由冷冻干燥水果制成，带来爆发性的电感风味。全新的红牛能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，详情请见麦当劳官网McDonald's.ca，适用于加拿大参与活动的餐厅，魁北克省除外。嘿，我是Hayes，Davenport和Sean Clements。
We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. we talk to someone in show business and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, Adam Scott, Danny McBride, Ben Stillard, and a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. them. I'm Elizabeth Smart and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live
我们主持播客《好莱坞手册》。我们与演艺圈的人交谈，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人因为让公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们有很多很棒的嘉宾，比如Sarah Sherman，Adam Scott，Danny McBride，Ben Stiller，还有很多如果没有我们就不可能有今天成就的大人物。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《好莱坞手册》。我在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是Elizabeth Smart，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会与幸存者在一起，他们经历
through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
了不可想象的事情，被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。这些故事讲述了如何活着走出来。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听Elizabeth Smart的《幸存者档案》。在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙提议让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是Julie Pinero，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“是”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性来交换怜悯。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Solita》。
If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks pride and prejudice and love island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Speck and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here
如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。《Pro Society》是一档每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》具有同等话语权的人。每周，我们都会与您最喜欢的作家、书评创作者以及大量过度思考的观点一起，连接书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的点点滴滴。是的，我着迷了。我着迷了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Pro Society》。大家好。我是Jemma Speck，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能在这里
back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I have a very fun, or at least I think it's fun, very fascinating at least, in-depth science episode for you all today about the big hunk of flesh in your skull, your brain. I think most of us know a few interesting facts about the brain. We know it's 75% water, that there are things called neurons and synapses. Maybe you can even label the four major lobes if you paid close enough attention in Year 10 biology. But do you actually understand why your brain behaves the way it does. Why you can remember an embarrassing moment from 12 years ago, but forget what you have for breakfast yesterday. And certain habits seem impossible to break, whilst others
回到另一集，我们当然要剖析二十岁的心理学。今天我为大家准备了一个非常有趣，或者至少我认为很有趣，至少是非常迷人的深度科学剧集，关于你头骨里那块大肉块——你的大脑。我想我们大多数人都知道一些关于大脑的有趣事实。我们知道它75%是水，有神经元和突触之类的东西。如果你在十年级生物课上足够专心，也许你甚至能标出四个主要脑叶。但你真的了解为什么你的大脑会有这样的行为吗？为什么你能记住12年前的一个尴尬时刻，却忘记了昨天早餐吃了什么？而某些习惯似乎无法打破，而另一些
you don't have to try very hard for. These are all questions to do with your brain and to do with how this thing in your head is structured and works. The more neuroscience I read, the more humbled I become because every thought you have, every memory you keep, every emotion you feel, even pain, every decision you make is the product of an organ weighing just over a kilo that somehow manages to build your entire experience of reality. And yet most of us go through life knowing surprisingly very little. So today I wanted to do something a little bit different, rather than just focusing on one psychological concept, we are going to explore seven of the most surprising and genuinely useful facts about your brain that you may not know. And even if you do
你却不需要太努力。这些都是关于你的大脑以及你头里的这个东西是如何构建和运作的问题。我读的神经科学越多，我就越感到谦卑，因为你的每一个想法、每一个记忆、每一种情绪，甚至痛苦，每一个决定，都是一个重量刚过一公斤的器官的产物，它竟然设法构建了你对现实的全部体验。然而，我们大多数人对它的了解却少得惊人。所以今天我想做点不同的事情，而不是只关注一个心理学概念，我们将探索关于你的大脑的七个最令人惊讶且真正有用的事实，你可能不知道。即使你知道
provide a little bit more of the little known research behind those facts, just to give you something interesting to talk about at dinner parties, but also so that you understand yourself better. More than that, I really do hope that you'll just leave with a greater appreciation for the genuine miracle that is your brain and how to take its quirks and its strange idiosyncrasies and use them to your advantage. Without further ado, let's get into it. Let's come out of the gate strong. Number one, your brain can physically rewire itself, even if it's injured, even if entire parts of your brain are removed, you might have heard of the term neuroplasticity. And this is exactly what we're talking about here. A very good definition,
提供一点这些事实背后鲜为人知的研究，不仅是为了让你在晚宴上有谈资，也是为了让你更好地了解自己。不仅如此，我真的希望你能带着对大脑这个真正奇迹的更大赞赏离开，并了解如何利用它的怪癖和奇怪的特质来发挥你的优势。废话少说，让我们开始吧。让我们开门见山。第一，你的大脑可以物理重塑自身，即使它受伤了，即使大脑的某些部分被切除了，你可能听说过“神经可塑性”这个词。这正是我们在这里讨论的内容。一个很好的定义，
probably the best definition of neuroplasticity I've come across, is basically it is the ability for your nervous system, including your brain, to change its activity in response to intrinsic and extrinsic stimuli by reorganizing its structures, its functions, its connections. In other words, our brain can adapt due to experience. This is what allows us to learn new skills, to recover after strokes or traumatic brain injuries, and also to change our deep ways of being and our thought patterns and our habits. If we didn't have neuroplasticity, we wouldn't be capable of any kind of personal evolution. We wouldn't be capable of any kind of adaptation. This is our brain's first superpower. Our brain is very good at working out what we need and what we don't need. It's a bit of a
可能是我遇到过的关于神经可塑性最好的定义，基本上它是你的神经系统（包括大脑）通过重组其结构、功能和连接，以响应内在和外在刺激来改变其活动的能力。换句话说，我们的大脑可以根据经验进行适应。这使我们能够学习新技能，在中风或创伤性脑损伤后恢复，并改变我们深层的存在方式、思维模式和习惯。如果我们没有神经可塑性，我们就无法进行任何形式的个人进化。我们就无法进行任何形式的适应。这是我们大脑的第一个超能力。我们的大脑非常擅长找出我们需要什么和不需要什么。它本质上是一个
an efficiency machine at its core. And this is how it carries out that efficiency plan through neuroplasticity. The thing is, we didn't really know the neural basis of this until probably 60 years ago or so. Our brains are composed of around 100 billion, billion with a B neurons. And early researchers really thought that, you know, that kind of creation of new neurons stopped shortly after birth. And we now know that is not true. And that throughout our lives, we can reorganize pathways. We can create new connections.
效率机器。这就是它通过神经可塑性执行该效率计划的方式。问题是，直到大约60年前，我们才真正知道其神经基础。我们的大脑由大约1000亿（带B的十亿）个神经元组成。早期的研究人员真的认为，那种新神经元的产生在出生后不久就停止了。我们现在知道这不是真的。而且在我们的一生中，我们可以重组路径。我们可以建立新的连接。
And in some cases, we can even create new neurons, especially in our late teens and in our 20s. Now, there are two main types of neuroplasticity that are very important for you to know if you want to change anything about who you are as a person. Firstly, is functional plasticity. this is the brain's ability to move functions from a damaged area of the brain to another undamaged area. This is mainly in response to things like trauma, but I mean physical trauma. It is the equivalent of riding your bike around a pothole to avoid falling in. And this happens in three ways. So functional neuroplasticity has three ways of operating, neuronal unmasking.
在某些情况下，我们甚至可以产生新的神经元，特别是在我们的青春期后期和二十多岁时。现在，如果你想改变作为一个人的任何方面，有两种主要的神经可塑性类型是你必须知道的。首先是功能可塑性。这是大脑将功能从受损区域转移到另一个未受损区域的能力。这主要是对创伤（我是指身体创伤）的反应。这相当于骑自行车绕过坑洼以避免摔倒。这通过三种方式发生。所以功能性神经可塑性有三种运作方式：神经元解蔽。
So basically the brain opens up dormant or backup. synapses that were previously inactive to take over damaged tissue nearby. Axonal sprouting, undamaged neurons grow new nerve endings known as axons to reconnect with other pathways and to build kind of lost networks. This is like the part of you that comes in and builds bridges that were, I guess, bombed. And then there's neural network adaptation. Neighboring, healthy regions become more engaged and take on new roles. So we We have reinforcements, bridge building, and then regional relocating. I genuinely cannot explain how amazing it is that your brain can do that.
基本上，大脑打开了以前不活跃的休眠或备份突触，以接管附近受损的组织。轴突发芽，未受损的神经元长出新的神经末梢（称为轴突），以重新连接其他路径并建立某种丢失的网络。这就像是你身体里进来并建造那些被炸毁的桥梁的部分。然后是神经网络适应。邻近的健康区域变得更加活跃并承担新的角色。所以我们有增援、桥梁建设，然后是区域重定位。我真的无法解释你的大脑能做到这一点是多么令人惊叹。
I feel like I'm going to use the word miracle so many times, but it is almost miraculous that we have this entire task force of neurons dedicated to helping us survive really awful things, damaging things, and to still function. Now, the second way neuroplasticity takes place is through something called structural plasticity. Structural plasticity is the brain's ability to actually change its physical structure as a result of learning. And I don't just mean sitting down with a textbook learning, but learning through everyday life. Instead of just kind of changing the strength of existing signals or, you know, moving things around, it can physically alter its chemical and cellular makeup so that it
我觉得我会用“奇迹”这个词很多次，但我们拥有整个神经元特遣队致力于帮助我们从非常糟糕、破坏性的事情中幸存下来，并继续运作，这几乎是奇迹。现在，神经可塑性发生的第二种方式是通过所谓的结构可塑性。结构可塑性是大脑因学习而实际改变其物理结构的能力。我指的不仅仅是坐下来看教科书学习，而是通过日常生活学习。它不仅仅是改变现有信号的强度或移动东西，它还可以物理地改变其化学和细胞构成，从而使它
looks physically different. Certain areas of our brain can gain more volume and become more dense. And you can see this on brain imaging scans. The more you learn or train or mentally challenge yourself, the more gray matter you may get. And this is something that you can really do for most of your life. That does kind of become a tipping point, but most of your life, you get the density of your brain. There are some limits to neuroplasticity, you know, for example, certain areas of your brain that are responsible for very specific actions, can't be moved. So if the part of your brain that is responsible for language is severely damaged, this can't always be converted, or part of your brain that's responsible for converting short-term to long-term memory is damage. Again, it's not like
看起来在物理上有所不同。我们大脑的某些区域可以获得更多的体积并变得更致密。你可以在脑部影像扫描中看到这一点。你学习、训练或挑战自己的次数越多，你可能获得的灰质就越多。这是你一生中大部分时间都可以做的事情。确实存在一个临界点，但在你生命的大部分时间里，你可以获得大脑的密度。神经可塑性有一些限制，例如，你大脑中负责非常特定动作的某些区域是无法移动的。所以如果你的大脑中负责语言的部分受到严重损害，这并不总是可以转换的，或者你大脑中负责将短期记忆转换为长期记忆的部分受到损害。同样，这也不是说
we can rewire that completely. But in general, at nearly any stage of your life, you can influence the flexibility of your brain, your neural networks, perhaps even the very structure of your brain through learning and through your actions and also through your thoughts and what you practice telling yourself or what you practice striving for or just doing. I think we believe that at some stage we just are the person we are and nothing's going to change about that. This is just who I always am going to be. And neuroplasticity disproves this entirely.
我们可以完全重塑它。但总的来说，在你生命的几乎任何阶段，你都可以通过学习、行动以及你的思想，以及你练习告诉自己什么，或者你练习追求什么，或者仅仅是去做什么，来影响你的大脑、你的神经网络，甚至可能是你大脑本身的结构。我认为我们相信在某个阶段我们就是我们自己，没有什么会改变。这就是我永远的样子。而神经可塑性完全反驳了这一点。
Your brain remains plastic for your entire life pretty much. especially if you give it the certain conditions under which to do so. So I want to talk about some very simple science-backed ways to actually promote neuroplasticity if you want to keep your brain in this malleable state, the very first one being learning. If you want to keep your brain plastic and malleable and flexible, learning should be a lifelong pursuit. And not just, as I said, in an academic sense, in a school sense, but in a private sense as well, learning a new language, getting back to crafting or making art, you know, reading instead of doom scrolling, learning how to do things with your hands, learning new skills, they all count.
你的大脑几乎在你的一生中都保持可塑性。特别是如果你给它提供这样做的一定条件。所以我想谈谈一些非常简单的、有科学依据的方法来实际促进神经可塑性，如果你想让你的大脑保持这种可塑状态的话。第一个就是学习。如果你想让你的大脑保持可塑、可塑性和灵活性，学习应该是一生的追求。正如我所说，不仅仅是在学术意义上，在学校意义上，而且在私人意义上也是如此，学习一门新语言，重新开始手工制作或艺术创作，阅读而不是无意识地刷手机，学习如何用手做事，学习新技能，这些都算数。
Your brain remains flexible as long as you give it a reason to do so. As long as you say there's a reason that we want you to be this way, because we are going to give you new information, we are going to give you new skills. So giving it learning material basically is a way to do that. The second way to maintain neuroplasticity is to play more. I think we look down at people who are a little bit silly, but having fun is one of the most neurologically powerful things that you can do for your brain health. There was one very important 2014 paper published in the Journal of Brain Imaging and
只要你给它一个理由，你的大脑就会保持灵活性。只要你说有一个理由让我们希望你这样，因为我们将给你新的信息，我们将给你新的技能。所以给它学习材料基本上就是一种方法。保持神经可塑性的第二种方法是多玩。我认为我们看不起那些有点傻的人，但玩得开心是你为大脑健康所能做的最强大的神经学事情之一。2014年发表在《大脑成像与行为》杂志上的一篇非常重要的论文，
behavior, and it found that people who maintain their playfulness into adulthood. So people who play cards, who play outside, who play with their pets, play with their friends. They had significantly higher gray matter volume than people who did not do these things. They also minimized their Alzheimer's risk. They minimized physical health risks. They didn't really have to do anything else. It wasn't like it was this arduous task. They just had to have fun. That is so important for your brain health and your own neuroplasticity, actually enjoying yourself and being playful. The third way to maintain your plasticity, be very careful about how you speak to yourself. You are the first point of contact between your brain and the world around
它发现那些在成年后保持顽皮心态的人。所以那些玩纸牌、在户外玩、和宠物玩、和朋友玩的人。他们的灰质体积明显高于不做这些事情的人。他们还最大限度地降低了患阿尔茨海默病的风险。他们最大限度地降低了身体健康风险。他们真的不需要做任何其他事情。这不像是一项艰巨的任务。他们只需要玩得开心。这对你的大脑健康和你自己的神经可塑性非常重要，实际上是享受自己并保持顽皮。保持可塑性的第三种方法，非常小心你对自己说话的方式。你是你的大脑与周围世界之间的第一个接触点
you. So if you say to yourself, you know, that's not possible for someone like me or the world is just really against me. If you say that enough times, just you thinking that is the only evidence your brain actually needs to believe it and to make a pathway directly to that way of seeing things. Just watch how quickly those thoughts now become your reality because your brain refused. to search for anything different. If you have fed it this information, if you have said this is how the world is, of course it's going to believe you, of course it's going to trust you. So be very careful with how you speak to yourself. And finally, and very similar to my above point, I think just know that your brain is malleable. Just know that your brain is flexible. That alone helps with
。所以如果你对自己说，你知道，这对像我这样的人来说是不可能的，或者世界真的与我作对。如果你说了足够多次，仅仅是你这样想，就是你的大脑真正需要相信它并直接建立通往那种看待事物方式的路径的唯一证据。看看这些想法很快就会变成你的现实，因为你的大脑拒绝寻找任何不同的东西。如果你已经喂养了它这些信息，如果你已经说这就是世界的样子，它当然会相信你，它当然会信任你。所以要非常小心你对自己说话的方式。最后，与我上面的观点非常相似，我认为只要知道你的大脑是可塑的。只要知道你的大脑是灵活的。仅这一点就有助于
neuroplasticity. An example of this is a study that was done in the US over a two-year period on teenagers and it looked at how beliefs about learning could have an impact upon achievement, especially in math. And the study found that teenagers who were taught that their brain was malleable, their intelligence was malleable, their intellect was malleable, that they could make themselves smarter, basically, just being taught that and nothing else significantly meant that they were going to outperform those who weren't taught this. Basically, they did better because they believe that they could and because they understood that their brain was not fixed. So neuroplasticity, it works in our favor. It's also a powerful weapon in both directions. You have to remember
神经可塑性。一个例子是美国在两年期间对青少年进行的一项研究，它观察了关于学习的信念如何对成就产生影响，特别是在数学方面。研究发现，被教导大脑是可塑的、智力是可塑的、才智是可塑的、他们可以让自己变得更聪明的青少年，仅仅被教导这一点，没有别的，就意味着他们将显著优于那些没有被教导这一点的人。基本上，他们做得更好，因为他们相信他们可以，因为他们明白他们的大脑不是固定的。所以神经可塑性，它对我们有利。它也是两个方向上的强大武器。你必须记住
whatever you feed your brain regularly in terms of thoughts, behaviors, actions. It is built to respond to that. It is flexible to your way of seeing the world and those ways of thinking will become your default. Now that you know about it, hopefully you can control it. So brain fact number two, your brain feels pain, not the body, which is why emotional pain can feel just as awful as the physical kind. We have this belief that physical pain and mental pain are pretty much distinct, they're separate, and we also have this belief that one is worse than the other. Breaking a leg is worse than a broken heart, but psychology is increasingly demonstrating the opposite of that. When people feel emotional pain, the same areas of the brain get activated as when people feel a physical hurt.
无论你定期给大脑喂养什么，就思想、行为、行动而言。它是为了响应这一点而构建的。它对你观察世界的方式很灵活，这些思维方式将成为你的默认设置。既然你知道了这一点，希望你能控制它。所以大脑事实之二，你的大脑感到疼痛，而不是身体，这就是为什么情感痛苦可以感觉和身体痛苦一样糟糕。我们有一种信念，即身体疼痛和精神疼痛几乎是不同的，它们是分开的，我们也有一种信念，即一种比另一种更糟。断腿比心碎更糟，但心理学正越来越多地证明事实恰恰相反。当人们感到情感痛苦时，大脑中被激活的区域与人们感到身体伤害时相同。
In one study, actually, they had all these researchers, they created a situation of what we call experimental social rejection. So basically, they made it seem like people in this experiment were being rejected by real humans. And the way they did that was they got people to play a virtual ball game. And they would toss the ball between them and these other virtual people who they were told were real people. And then at some stage in the game, nobody would toss to them anymore. And whilst this was happening, they hooked them up to brain imaging devices just to see how their brain was responding to this social rejection and this sense of being outcast. What scans showed is that the areas of the brain that light up when physical pain is experienced, specifically
在一项研究中，实际上，他们让所有这些研究人员创造了一种我们称之为“实验性社会排斥”的情况。所以基本上，他们让人们在这个实验中看起来像是被真实的人类拒绝了。他们这样做的方法是让人们玩一个虚拟球类游戏。他们会在他们和这些其他虚拟人之间扔球，他们被告知这些人是真实的人。然后在游戏的某个阶段，没有人再把球扔给他们了。当这种情况发生时，他们把他们连接到脑部成像设备上，只是为了看看他们的大脑是如何对这种社会排斥和这种被排斥感做出反应的。扫描显示，当经历身体疼痛时，大脑中亮起的区域，特别是
the anterior insular and the anterior singular. Antirious, cortex, actually, to be specific, those regions were also activated in what seemed like very benign and definitely not physically painful scenarios. It's not physically painful to be rejected, but we still feel it on a deeper level because of this neural representation of pain. Another study took this a step further, and it looked at people's brains in conditions of real social rejection, so not experimental social rejection, but real life. And the way they did that was they showed participants pictures of former romantic partners who had broken up with them. Very cruel, how they got access to these pictures as well, a little bit, I don't really know how they did, but they did.
前岛叶和前扣带皮层，实际上，具体来说，这些区域在看起来非常良性且绝对没有身体痛苦的情况下也被激活了。被拒绝在身体上并不痛苦，但由于这种疼痛的神经表征，我们仍然在更深层次上感受到它。另一项研究将这一点更进一步，它观察了人们在真实社会排斥条件下的脑部情况，所以不是实验性社会排斥，而是现实生活。他们这样做的方法是向参与者展示与他们分手的前浪漫伴侣的照片。非常残忍，他们是如何获得这些照片的，也有点，我真的不知道他们是怎么做到的，但他们做到了。
And again, they put them up, they attached them to a brain imaging scan, and the same regions of the brain were activated as physical pain activates as well. Basically, emotional, social, physical pain, all of them share what we call somatosensory representation. they are mapped to the same region. If we want to take this even a step further, there have been certain experiments that have shown that just taking drugs that are normally associated with reducing physical pain, so ibuprofen, Advil, aspirin, panadol,
同样，他们把他们放上去，连接到脑部成像扫描仪上，大脑中被激活的区域与身体疼痛激活的区域相同。基本上，情感、社会、身体疼痛，它们都共享我们所说的躯体感觉表征。它们被映射到同一个区域。如果我们想把这一点再进一步，有一些实验表明，仅仅服用通常与减轻身体疼痛相关的药物，即布洛芬、Advil、阿司匹林、必理通，
I don't know what you guys all call them, but panadol, that kind of thing, just taking those can have an impact on how emotional pain is received or perceived as well. So in one study in 2010 by researchers in the UK, people who had experienced a recent social rejection were randomly assigned to take paracetamol versus a placebo every day for three weeks. The people who took the drug reported fewer, basically hurt feelings. So this was a randomly controlled study. When their brains were scanned at the very end of the treatment period, we would call it, the people who had taken power.
我不知道你们都叫它们什么，但必理通，那种东西，仅仅服用这些药物也会对情感痛苦的接收或感知产生影响。所以在一项2010年由英国研究人员进行的研究中，经历过近期社会排斥的人被随机分配每天服用扑热息痛或安慰剂，持续三周。服用该药物的人报告说，基本上受伤的感觉更少。所以这是一项随机对照研究。当他们的脑部在治疗期结束时（我们称之为治疗期）被扫描时，服用扑热息痛的人
paracetamol, had less activation in that anterior insular and anterior cigulic cortex. A lot of our brain's perception of pain is very emotional and it's closely linked to our mental health as well. This is why many people notice improvements in their perception of pain when they sleep better, when they reduce stress, when they increase social connection, or when they get professional help. It's also why people whose pain is repeatedly dismissed by healthcare professionals will notice their pain getting worse for a couple of reasons, A, because their symptoms aren't being addressed or treated, but also because their mind feels rejected and less capable of dealing with this pain because they are being dismissed. The social dismissal and social
在前岛叶和前扣带皮层中的激活较少。我们大脑对疼痛的感知很大程度上是非常情绪化的，它也与我们的心理健康密切相关。这就是为什么许多人在睡眠更好、减轻压力、增加社会联系或获得专业帮助时，会注意到他们对疼痛的感知有所改善。这也是为什么那些疼痛被医疗专业人员反复忽视的人会注意到他们的疼痛变得更糟的原因，有两个原因：A，因为他们的症状没有得到解决或治疗，但也因为他们的思想感到被拒绝，并且因为他们被忽视而不太有能力处理这种疼痛。社会忽视和社会
rejection effects are impacting the same region where the chronic pain is also being experienced as well. And so you have this cumulative load of painful experiences making each one worse. Everything is connected. We have to stop treating health like it's these distinct pillars that need to be addressed one by one, you know, mental health first, then physical health, then social health. We have to stop treating physical pain like it's more serious than mental pain. And unless you have a wound or a scar, like you really need to get over it, all of it is interrelated and interconnected and comes down to how your brain is operating. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, and then when we return, I want to talk about movies,
排斥效应正在影响慢性疼痛所经历的同一区域。因此，你有了这种痛苦经历的累积负荷，使每一次都变得更糟。一切都是相互关联的。我们必须停止像对待需要一个一个解决的独立支柱那样对待健康，你知道，先是心理健康，然后是身体健康，然后是社会健康。我们必须停止像对待身体疼痛比精神疼痛更严重那样对待它。除非你有伤口或疤痕，否则你真的需要克服它，所有这些都是相互关联和相互连接的，归根结底在于你的大脑是如何运作的。好了，我们在这里休息一下，当我们回来时，我想谈谈电影，
specifically what movies get wrong about the brain. Stay with us. Red Bull, Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details of McDonald's. dot CA at participating Canadian restaurants excluding Quebec. If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks pride and prejudice and love
特别是电影对大脑的误解。请继续关注我们。红牛龙莓和热带莓能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市，由冷冻干燥水果制成，带来爆发性的电感风味。全新的红牛能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，详情请见麦当劳官网McDonald's.ca，适用于加拿大参与活动的餐厅，魁北克省除外。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《Pro Society》，每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合思想女儿、流行文化痴迷者，以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱》
island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse.
岛具有同等话语权的人。我是Eli Rallo，每周我们都在连接书籍、互联网和每个人都无法停止谈论的对话之间的点点滴滴。我得去查查这个故事。我着迷了。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的书评创作者到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可以谈论的。这就像如果你能把一些真实的信息隐藏在引人注目的角色中，那么这就是特洛伊木马。
Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive
无论你是在寻找文学深度解析、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢思考太多的读者社区，你都来对地方了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Pro Society》。在书页之间见。当我14岁时，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我幸存了下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何幸存下来的
what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice, next to my ear saying shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
那些本应摧毁他们的东西。我是Elizabeth Smart，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得那个低沉、嘲弄的声音，在我耳边说闭嘴，什么都别说。每周，我都会与幸存者在一起，他们经历不可想象的事情。我当时知道，如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始感觉到床尾有人，我就开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。
But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can see. say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity
但这些故事不是关于从他们身上夺走了什么。而是关于如何活着走出来。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听Elizabeth Smart的《幸存者档案》。在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙提议让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是Julie Pinero，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“是”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性来交换怜悯。
for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So, So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements.
每次我试图独处时，我都会遇到人，他们会说，你对我们笑了。这里没有多少人笑。当你独处时，你最能接受世界本来的样子，而不是关于它的谎言。这可以是一个你突破极限、改变主意或唤醒新自我的时间。所以，无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是太紧张而不敢预订第一次旅行，我希望你在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《Solita》。嘿，我是Hayes Davenport。还有Sean Clements。
We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook on the Big Money Players Network. Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners. Each week, we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz, and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, not that great. Actually, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head, right? How about we flip this script?
我们在Big Money Players Network主持播客《好莱坞手册》。我们的节目对第一次听的人非常友好。每周，我们与演艺圈的人（又名“圈内”）交谈，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人因为让公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们有很多很棒的嘉宾，比如Sarah Sherman，没那么棒。其实，你能帮我塑造一下这个吗？我们把它反过来怎么样？我们把这个剧本翻转过来怎么样？
What is the surprise woman? Actually, you think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird. Adam Scott. This entire time, you've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to the, visit the show. I would never expect. I would never set expectations for something like that to happen. If the
什么是惊喜女人？其实，你认为是直男的人实际上是那个行为怪异的人。Adam Scott。这一直以来，你一直期待Adam Sandler来访问节目。我永远不会期待。我永远不会为这种事情发生设定期望。如果
universe allows for something like that to happen, I'm open to it. I'm always going to accept. You know, Danny McBride, fine. Yeah, it's all this fragile masculinity exuding. I could smell it walking down the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, is that weed? Nope.
宇宙允许这种事情发生，我对此持开放态度。我总是会接受。你知道，Danny McBride，很好。是的，这全是这种脆弱的男子气概在散发。老实说，我走在走廊上都能闻到。我在想，那是大麻吗？不。
It's fragile masculinity. Ben Stiller, no. Because a lot of times out of context, people don't get it or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? They're like, oh, what's a state? Everyone's so dumb. And fake. Right.
那是脆弱的男子气概。Ben Stiller，不。因为很多时候在语境之外，人们不明白，甚至不知道什么是圆圈。你知道我的意思吗？他们会说，哦，什么是状态？每个人都太笨了。而且虚假。对。
Fake and also not interested or just like, oh, I've got my life. I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. So I said we were going to talk about movies. We're actually going to talk about two in particular.
虚假，而且也不感兴趣，或者只是说，哦，我有我的生活。我不关心你的生活。还有很多其他如果没有我们就不可能有今天成就的大人物。哦，顺便说一句，Will Ferrell亲自告诉我们他喜欢这个节目，他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他太忙了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《好莱坞手册》。所以我说我们要谈谈电影。我们实际上要谈谈两部特别的电影。
The first one is Lucy, the movie Lucy. I watched this couple nights ago with my boyfriend and to jog your memory. I think it came out in like 2014, 2013 with Scarlett Johansson and Morgan Freeman. And in the movie, Scarlett Johansson, she gets like drugged with this drug that causes her to use more than 10% of her brain and she suddenly becomes this superhuman and it's basically the exact same movie as or the movie plot as the movie Limitless with Bradley Cooper. Literally same thing. Bradley takes a drug that allows him to use 100% of his brain. He becomes very smart, blah, blah, blah. When I say these are the same movie, they are basically, I genuinely think that like the script
第一部是《超体》，电影《超体》。我前几天晚上和男朋友看了这部电影，为了唤起你的记忆。我想它是在2014年、2013年左右出来的，由Scarlett Johansson和Morgan Freeman主演。在电影中，Scarlett Johansson，她被这种药物毒害，导致她使用超过10%的大脑，她突然变成了这个超人，这基本上和电影《永无止境》的剧情一模一样，Bradley Cooper主演。字面意思一样。Bradley服用了一种药物，允许他使用100%的大脑。他变得非常聪明，等等等等。当我说这是同一部电影时，它们基本上是，我真的认为那个剧本
was accidentally dropped off at two of the same offices at the same time. So if you've watched one, you've probably watched the other. But these two movies are very critical because it was these movies that popularize the idea that we only use a small section of our brain, 10% to be specific. Now, this theory didn't begin in Hollywood. It was popularized in Hollywood, but it began with two Harvard psychologists, their names were William James and Boris Siddis. And they first wrote about this theory in this big paper that they released in the 1890s. And they said, guess what? We only used 10% of our brain. If you were going to ask what scientific evidence they had for that, they basically didn't have any. They didn't have any. But they had a theory. They said,
是意外地同时被送到两个相同的办公室。所以如果你看过其中一部，你可能就看过另一部。但这两部电影非常关键，因为正是这些电影普及了我们只使用大脑的一小部分，具体来说是10%的想法。现在，这个理论并非始于好莱坞。它在好莱坞被普及，但它始于两位哈佛心理学家，他们的名字是William James和Boris Siddis。他们第一次在1890年代发表的一篇大论文中写到了这个理论。他们说，猜猜怎么着？我们只使用了大脑的10%。如果你要问他们有什么科学证据，他们基本上没有任何证据。他们没有任何证据。但他们有一个理论。他们说，
you know, humans don't use everything, all the flesh in them in their head. And their theory also said that the first person who could use 100% of their brain would be this mega genius. And an interesting part of this story is that they then went on. Well, Boris went on to try and raise his son this way. He tried to raise his son to be a super genius to use 100% of his brain. I feel like we all know how that turned out. This guy, this kid, really, he went to Harvard when he was 11, he wrote all these books, and then basically he, like, fell off the face of the earth and had, like, a terrible mental health crisis and was never seen again. But when this big theory was going around and when it was first released in, like, the 1890s and the early 1900s, people loved it. People loved this idea
你知道，人类并没有使用他们头里的所有肉。他们的理论还说，第一个能使用100%大脑的人将是一个超级天才。这个故事的一个有趣部分是，他们后来继续。好吧，Boris继续尝试以这种方式抚养他的儿子。他试图把他的儿子培养成一个超级天才，使用他100%的大脑。我觉得我们都知道结果如何。这个家伙，这个孩子，真的，他在11岁时就去了哈佛，他写了所有这些书，然后基本上他就像从地球上消失了一样，经历了一场可怕的心理健康危机，再也没有出现过。但当这个大理论流传开来，当它在1890年代和1900年代初首次发布时，人们喜欢它。人们喜欢这个想法
that we could all be secret geniuses if we just took a pill or used 100% of our brain. And it created a lot of these, what our modern day equivalent would be click date articles and newspapers. And it became very popular and then forgotten. And then there was a resurgence of the idea with those movies, Limitless and Lucy. Is that true? Do we only use 10% of our brain? No. The actual truth is that we use all of our brain, all of it. Even if not all neurons are firing at the same time, we use all of our brain. This became quite glaringly obvious. with the invention of the MRI machine, which basically showed that there is widespread ongoing activity and most of the brain at any given time. Even when we're asleep, we are using more than 10%
如果我们只是吃一颗药或使用100%的大脑，我们都可以成为秘密天才。它创造了很多我们现代等同于点击诱饵的文章和报纸。它变得非常流行，然后被遗忘了。然后随着那些电影《永无止境》和《超体》的出现，这个想法又复苏了。那是真的吗？我们真的只使用大脑的10%吗？不。事实是，我们使用我们所有的大脑，全部。即使不是所有的神经元都在同一时间放电，我们也使用我们所有的大脑。这变得非常明显。随着MRI机器的发明，它基本上显示在任何给定时间，大脑的大部分都有广泛的持续活动。即使在我们睡觉时，我们也使用超过10%
of our brain. What's more, our brain only accounts for 2% of our body mass, but about 20% of our energy consumption. In infants specifically, the brain uses about 60% of our everyday caloric intake. Now, from an evolutionary perspective, there is just no way that such an energy costly organ could be so underused that we would only require 10% of it at any given time. Humans would never have evolved to have brains anywhere near the size that we do if we didn't use every single part of it. I think any time you see a statement or a finding that simplifies things so perfectly, and without any exceptions, you can tell it's false. 10% is just too specific of a number and for it to apply to absolutely every single person without any considerations or without any kind of second guess without any caveats is just ridiculous. So you use way more than 10% of your brain, you use every single part of it.
的大脑。更重要的是，我们的大脑仅占我们体重的2%，但约占我们能量消耗的20%。特别是在婴儿中，大脑消耗了我们日常热量摄入的约60%。现在，从进化的角度来看，根本没有理由让这样一个能量昂贵的器官被如此低效地使用，以至于我们在任何给定时间只需要它的10%。如果人类没有使用它的每一个部分，我们就永远不会进化出接近我们现在大小的大脑。我认为任何时候你看到一个如此完美地简化事情，且没有任何例外的陈述或发现，你就可以看出它是假的。10%是一个太具体的数字，它适用于绝对每一个人，没有任何考虑，没有任何二次猜测，没有任何警告，这简直是荒谬的。所以你使用的大脑远不止10%，你使用它的每一个部分。
Anybody who tries to tell you otherwise has probably gotten that information from a Hollywood blockbuster. Fact number four. your brain and your stomach are deeply, deeply linked. There is a known two-way communication pathway between your gut and your brain, and it's known as the gut-brain axis. This connection is physical. It connects to the vagus nerve, and it's chemical as well via neurotransmitters. They are in constant communication. This is part of the reason why our gut, I don't know if you've heard it referred to this is sometimes called the second brain. Scientists also call it the enteric nervous
任何试图告诉你相反情况的人可能都是从好莱坞大片中获得的信息。事实之四。你的大脑和你的胃是深深地、深深地联系在一起的。你的肠道和大脑之间存在一条已知的双向通信路径，它被称为肠脑轴。这种连接是物理的。它连接到迷走神经，并且通过神经递质也是化学的。它们处于持续的通信中。这就是为什么我们的肠道，我不知道你是否听说过它被称为这个，有时被称为“第二个大脑”。科学家也称它为肠神经
system, or ENS for short. The ENS, as opposed to the CNS, central nervous system, is actually just two thin layers of more than 100 million nerve cells that line your gastrointestinal tract. Now, the main role of the ENS is controlling digestion from swallowing and through the release of enzymes so that we can break down our food, so that we can get energy, so that we can control blood flow, blood sugar, all that kind of stuff, and so that we can absorb and eliminate nutrients. It also plays a secondary role, which is, it impacts our mood. For example, our gut microbiome, so the microbes living in your gut right now, produce up to 95% of our serotonin. Serotonin, as we know it, is the happy chemical.
系统，简称ENS。ENS与CNS（中枢神经系统）相对，实际上只是两层薄薄的、超过1亿个神经细胞，排列在你的胃肠道中。现在，ENS的主要作用是控制消化，从吞咽到通过释放酶，以便我们可以分解食物，以便我们可以获得能量，以便我们可以控制血流、血糖，所有这些东西，以及以便我们可以吸收和消除营养。它还扮演着次要角色，即它影响我们的情绪。例如，我们的肠道微生物群，即现在生活在你肠道中的微生物，产生了我们高达95%的血清素。血清素，正如我们所知，是快乐化学物质。
That's its colloquial name. Now, the serotonin can't necessarily cross the blood-brain barrier, but it does assist with things like gut immunity, which therefore influences what energy you receive from food, the level of inflammation in your stomach and the level of toxicity as well. And also things like irritability, things like perception of pain once again, so many things. One 2023 study published in the journal Nature, which is a favorite on the podcast, even suggests that this relationship between gut health and overall happiness. is the reason why people with IBS or other stomach issues are significantly more likely to suffer from depression and anxiety. Now previously, scientists kind of thought, or doctors as well, thought that people who were anxious and depressed
这就是它的俗称。现在，血清素不一定能穿过血脑屏障，但它确实有助于肠道免疫等功能，从而影响你从食物中获得的能量、胃部的炎症水平以及毒性水平。此外，它还影响易怒情绪、对疼痛的感知等诸多方面。2023年发表在《自然》杂志上的一项研究（该播客非常推崇这本杂志）甚至提出，肠道健康与整体幸福感之间的这种关系，是肠易激综合征（IBS）或其他胃部问题患者更容易患上抑郁症和焦虑症的原因。此前，科学家或医生曾认为，那些焦虑和抑郁的人
were more likely to develop IBS-like symptoms, you know, like an upset stomach, like pain, like bloating, because of emotional distress, because they were so upset that this was putting stress on their stomach. it's increasingly understood that it may be the other way around and that IBS may be essentially an overcommunication between the gut and the brain. The symptoms that IBS creates like constipation, bloating, pain, stomach upset contribute to people feeling not as mentally healthy, feeling depressed and anxious because the irritated gastrointestinal system sends all these
更容易出现类似IBS的症状，比如因情绪困扰而导致的胃部不适、疼痛、腹胀，因为他们过于心烦意乱，从而给胃部造成了压力。但现在人们越来越认识到，情况可能恰恰相反，IBS本质上可能是肠道与大脑之间的一种过度沟通。IBS产生的症状，如便秘、腹胀、疼痛和胃部不适，会导致人们心理健康状况下降，感到抑郁和焦虑，因为受刺激的胃肠系统会发送所有这些
signals to the central nervous system that something is wrong, and that triggers mood changes. Doctors treating IBS may actually even at times prescribe certain antidepressants for this very reason to calm symptoms by acting on nerve cells in the gut and also by acting on that communication pathway or channel. Our gut also has a surprising role, I think I mentioned before, in how we perceive pain, when the gut microbiome is imbalanced, inflamed, disrupted by, stress, the gut brain access is once again negatively impacted. In particular, the brain's ability to process certain sensations properly, sustainably, effectively, is affected. And studies have shown that gut inflammation increases sensitivity to pain, also heightens anxiety, which increases perception
信号给中枢神经系统，告知其出了问题，从而引发情绪变化。治疗IBS的医生有时甚至会因为这个原因开具某些抗抑郁药，通过作用于肠道神经细胞以及作用于该沟通路径或通道来缓解症状。我认为我之前提到过，我们的肠道在感知疼痛方面也起着令人惊讶的作用。当肠道微生物群失衡、发炎或受到压力干扰时，肠脑轴再次受到负面影响。特别是大脑处理某些感觉的能力，即能否可持续、有效地处理这些感觉，会受到影响。研究表明，肠道炎症会增加对疼痛的敏感性，也会加剧焦虑，从而增加对
of pain, whilst alternatively a healthy microbiome can support emotional regulation and also reduce pain intensity. So this means that that food, stress, sleep, infections, even antibiotics drinking alcohol can alter how your brain senses the world around you, not just through your mind, but through your gut. The biggest way that I've noticed this, and this is going to sound so strange, and maybe there's a doctor listening to this is going to be like, you have nothing, this is ridiculous, but it's gum, it's chewing gum. I used to chew so much gum. I really cannot make it up. My stomach would be so sore so bloated, so upset. And since stopping, I feel like I'm so much less irritable. My mental health
疼痛的感知，而健康的微生物群则可以支持情绪调节并降低疼痛强度。这意味着食物、压力、睡眠、感染，甚至抗生素和饮酒，都会改变你的大脑感知周围世界的方式，不仅是通过你的思维，还通过你的肠道。我注意到这一点最明显的方式——这听起来可能很奇怪，也许有医生在听这个节目会觉得这简直是无稽之谈——那就是口香糖。我过去嚼太多口香糖了。我真的没编造。我的胃会非常痛、非常胀、非常不舒服。自从戒掉后，我觉得自己没那么容易烦躁了。我的心理健康
has gotten better. Day to day, to day, I'm much more patient. Now, this could be utterly ridiculous. It could be utterly unrelated. But the more I learn about this, the second brain, the more I do believe it, like, especially last year I was eating things, chewing things, drinking things. It definitely didn't make my stomach feel good and then definitely didn't make my brain feel good either. I don't think you thought I was going to be talking about stomach pains and diarrhea and upset stomachs in this episode. But yes, it does really, really impact and is directly related to how your brain operates. Okay, moving on, moving on from that to fact number five. And one we spoke about in an episode just a few weeks back, but which deserves its place on this list, I think, nonetheless.
变好了。日复一日，我变得更有耐心了。现在，这可能完全是荒谬的。这可能完全无关。但随着我对这个“第二大脑”了解得越多，我就越相信它，尤其是去年我吃的东西、嚼的东西、喝的东西。它们绝对没让我的胃感觉好受，也绝对没让我的大脑感觉好受。我想你没想到我会在这一集里谈论胃痛、腹泻和胃部不适。但确实，它真的、真的会产生影响，并且与你的大脑运作方式直接相关。好了，继续，从那一点继续到事实五。这是我们在几周前的一集里谈到过的一个事实，但我认为它仍然值得在这个名单上占有一席之地。
your brain actually can't multitask. It cannot multitask, at least not effectively, no matter what you believe. Lots of us like to think that we are able to kind of do two things at once fairly seamlessly. There's an old stereotype that women in particular are very good at multitasking. Unfortunately for us, a very, very famous study came out in 2013 that essentially said, sorry, that's not true. You're always sacrificing something. This study was done at the University of Utah by a man named David Sanbon Matsu, who is a professor of social psychology, and he's basically spent his entire career as a social psychologist and researcher looking into attention. His name will come up a
你的大脑实际上无法多任务处理。它无法多任务处理，至少无法有效做到，无论你相信什么。我们很多人喜欢认为自己能够相当顺畅地同时做两件事。有一个古老的刻板印象，认为女性尤其擅长多任务处理。不幸的是，2013年一项非常、非常著名的研究基本上说，抱歉，那不是真的。你总是在牺牲某些东西。这项研究是由犹他大学一位名叫大卫·桑邦·松（David Sanbonmatsu）的人进行的，他是一位社会心理学教授，他基本上整个职业生涯都作为社会心理学家和研究人员在研究注意力。他的名字会在你研究注意力时出现
couple of times whenever you're looking at attention research. But for this study, this is what he did. he recruited 300 undergraduate students. He had them do a questionnaire where he basically asked them, you know, how often do you use your cell phone when you're driving? Do you think that when you use your cell phone and you're driving, it impacts your driving? How well do you think you are at multitasking? How impulsive are you? How good are you at driving just in general?
几次。但对于这项研究，他是这样做的：他招募了300名本科生。他让他们做了一份问卷，基本上问他们：你开车时使用手机的频率是多少？你认为当你开车时使用手机会影响你的驾驶吗？你认为你的多任务处理能力如何？你有多冲动？你总体驾驶技术如何？
What about your motor skills? And then he tested them. He tested them on their abilities to multitask or drive whilst being on their phone with an automated computer task. Part of the computer task had subjects trying not to crash in a driving simulation whilst performing memory tasks and analysing math problems. And this computer task you had them do is actually a task that's used quite frequently in multitasking research.
你的运动技能如何？然后他测试了他们。他通过一项自动化计算机任务测试了他们在通话时进行多任务处理或驾驶的能力。计算机任务的一部分是让受试者在执行记忆任务和分析数学问题的同时，尽量不在驾驶模拟中发生碰撞。他让他们做的这项计算机任务实际上是多任务研究中经常使用的一项任务。
Participants are shown a sequence of letters. And if you've been a psych student and you've done psych studies, you may have done this before. You see a sequence of letters. And then in between those sequence of letters, you're asked to memory. them and then you're asked to do math problems. And then you do the math problem and then they say, what were the letters you saw before this? You can't remember. Sometimes you can and then you're given a score. What he found was A, the majority of these people were very overconfident about their multitasking ability. B, the majority of people were actually very bad at multitasking, but also,
参与者会看到一串字母。如果你是心理学专业的学生，做过心理学研究，你可能以前做过这个。你看到一串字母。然后在这些字母序列之间，你被要求记住它们，然后被要求做数学题。然后你做完数学题，他们会问，你之前看到的字母是什么？你记不住。有时你能记住，然后你会得到一个分数。他发现：A，这些人中的大多数对自己的多任务处理能力过于自信。B，大多数人实际上非常不擅长多任务处理，而且，
and this was the most surprising finding of all. The people who multitasked the most were the worst at it, the people who multitasked the least were the best at it. Like the people who were the best at multitasking, who could actually really had a knack for it, rarely did it. His study found that those rare individuals, the good multitaskers, they accounted for about 2% of all participants. So when he went back and he said to his students or to the participants,
这是最令人惊讶的发现。多任务处理最多的人表现最差，多任务处理最少的人表现最好。就像那些最擅长多任务处理、真正有天赋的人，很少这样做。他的研究发现，那些罕见的个体，即优秀的多任务处理者，约占所有参与者的2%。所以当他回去对他的学生或参与者说时，
okay, there's people who are good at multitasking. That's about 2%. And there's people who are bad. Which group do you think you're a part of? 93% of them said, well, of course, I'm in the really good group. Now, considering that group only represented 2% of people, a lot of them are wrong. A lot more research supports the fact that multitasking actually results in a cognitive cost to our brain. When we shift between tasks, our prefrontal cortex rapidly shifts attention.
“好吧，有擅长多任务处理的人。那大约占2%。还有不擅长的人。你认为你属于哪一组？”93%的人说：“嗯，当然，我属于非常擅长的那一组。”现在，考虑到该群体仅代表2%的人，他们中很多人是错的。更多的研究支持这样一个事实：多任务处理实际上会导致大脑的认知成本。当我们切换任务时，我们的前额叶皮层会迅速转移注意力。
Our working memory becomes overloaded, and this makes tasks take way longer than we anticipate. The thing is, you might think you're a good multitasker, and I certainly did because you don't really realize it into it's too late, and also because we confuse the novelty that comes with tasks switching with progress. We're doing all these things, something different, something different, something different, and that feels like progress, it's actually just distraction. This is why I think this fact belongs on this list, whether it is driving, or you're at work, or you're studying, whatever it is. When you multitask, you are forcing your brain to operate in a way that it doesn't naturally want to.
我们的工作记忆变得超负荷，这使得任务花费的时间比我们预期的要长得多。问题是，你可能认为自己是一个优秀的多任务处理者，我当然也这么认为，因为你直到为时已晚才意识到这一点，而且因为我们将任务切换带来的新鲜感与进步混为一谈。我们正在做所有这些事情，做点不同的，做点不同的，做点不同的，这感觉像是进步，实际上只是分心。这就是为什么我认为这个事实属于这个名单，无论是开车、工作还是学习，无论是什么。当你进行多任务处理时，你是在强迫你的大脑以它本能不想要的方式运作。
It can do it. It can, but it doesn't really want to. I saw somebody say that multitasking is for emergencies or nothing tasks, but very little in between. And I think I would have to agree, and I think you should too, knowing what we now know about how our brain is actually operating in these situations. Okay, I think we need to take one more break, but when we return, I have two more and two final essential learnings for you about your brain that I want to talk about.
它可以做到。它可以，但它真的不想。我看到有人说多任务处理适用于紧急情况或无意义的任务，但很少适用于两者之间。我想我不得不同意，而且我认为你也应该同意，了解了我们现在所知的关于我们的大脑在这些情况下是如何实际运作的。好了，我想我们需要再休息一下，但当我们回来时，我还有两个关于你大脑的最终重要知识点要讲。
So stay with us. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric bird. of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers. Now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details at McDonald's.cai at participating Canadian restaurants excluding Quebec. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files.
所以请留下来。全新的红牛龙果味和热带水果味能量饮料现已在麦当劳上市，由冷冻干燥水果和一种令人振奋的口味制成。全新的红牛能量饮料。现已在麦当劳上市。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，详情请咨询麦当劳。在参与活动的加拿大餐厅有售，魁北克省除外。我14岁时被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我活了下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特（Elizabeth Smart），这是《幸存者档案》（The Survivor Files）。
I just remember this low, taunting, voice next to my ear saying shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive.
我只记得耳边传来一个低沉、嘲弄的声音说：闭嘴，什么都别说。每周，我都会和经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒来，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始感觉到床尾有人，我就开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。但这些故事不是关于他们被夺走了什么。而是关于他们如何才能活着逃出来。
Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of distance. course. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. So I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《散文协会》（Prose Society），这是一个每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是思想女儿、流行文化痴迷者以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱之岛》值得同等程度关注的人的群聊。我得查查这个故事。我着迷了。所以我着迷了。从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的书评创作者到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可以谈论的。这就像如果你能隐藏一些真实的信息
inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle.
在引人入胜的角色中，那这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度解析、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢思考过多的读者社区，你都来对地方了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《散文协会》。在书页间见。在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时等下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙提议让我搭他的摩托车。
I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip,
我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“是”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”（独自一人）这个词，用可能性取代怜悯。每次我试图独处时，我都会遇到人，他们会说：你对我们笑了。这里没多少人笑。当你独处时，你最能接受世界的本来面目，而不是别人卖给你的关于它的谎言。这可以是一段你突破极限、改变主意或唤醒新自我的时光。所以，无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是太紧张而不敢预订第一次旅行，
I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook on the Big Money Players Network. Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners. Each week, we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz, and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show.
我希望你在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Solita》。嘿，我是海耶斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们在Big Money Players Network主持播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。我们的节目对首次听众非常友好。每周，我们都会与演艺界（又称“圈内”）的人交谈，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人因为公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。
We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, not that great. Actually, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head, right? How about we flip the script? What is the surprise woman? Actually, you think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird. Adam Scott. This entire time, you've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to the,
我们有很多很棒的嘉宾，比如莎拉·谢尔曼（Sarah Sherman），没那么棒。其实，你能帮我塑造一下这个吗？我们要不要把它颠倒过来？我们要不要改变剧本？什么是惊喜女性？其实，你认为是直男的人实际上是那个行为怪异的人。亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott）。一直以来，你都在期待亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）来，
visit the show. I would never let go of that. I have. I would never set expectations for something like that to happen. If the universe allows for something like that to happen, I'm open to it.
访问节目。我永远不会放过那个。我有。我永远不会对那种事情抱有期望。如果宇宙允许这种事情发生，我持开放态度。
I'm always going to accept. You know, Danny McBride, fine. Yeah. It's all this fragile masculinity exuding. I could smell it walking down the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, is that weed? Nope. It's fragile masculinity.
我总是会接受。你知道，丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride），很好。是的。这全是那种脆弱的男子气概在散发。老实说，我走在走廊上都能闻到。我在想，那是大麻吗？不。那是脆弱的男子气概。
Ben Stiller, no. Because a lot of times out of context, people don't get it or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? They're like, oh, it's so stupid. Everyone's so dumb except for you. And fake. Right, fake and also not interested or just like, oh, I've got my life. I don't care about your life.
本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller），不。因为很多时候脱离了语境，人们不明白，甚至不知道什么是圈子。你知道我的意思吗？他们会说，哦，太蠢了。除了你，每个人都很笨。而且虚伪。对，虚伪，而且不感兴趣，或者只是说，哦，我有我的生活。我不关心你的生活。
And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. So this just might be one of the most crucial, perhaps the most important insights from this entire episode, especially for my 20-somethings,
还有很多其他大人物，没有我们他们就不会有今天。哦，顺便说一句，威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）亲自告诉我们他喜欢这个节目，他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他太忙了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《好莱坞手册》。所以这可能是整个节目中最关键、也许是最重要的见解之一，特别是对于我的20多岁的听众，
which I'm going to assume is the majority of you, given the name of this podcast. Despite what you may have heard, your brain does not stop developing at 25. Your frontal lobe does not fully develop at that age and no other age. Your mid-20s are not a death sentence for your brain, development. It actually takes a long time for your brain to fully lock into place. And your brain development is very much a lifelong progress that has many iterations, many leaps, many different stages.
考虑到这个播客的名字，我假设你们大多数人都是。尽管你可能听说过，但你的大脑并没有在25岁时停止发育。你的额叶并没有在那个年龄或任何其他年龄完全发育。20多岁并不是你大脑发育的死刑。你的大脑完全定型实际上需要很长时间。你的大脑发育在很大程度上是一个终身的进步，有许多迭代、许多飞跃、许多不同的阶段。
So this idea of your frontal lobe kind of locking into place right at the point you turn 25, I think it's a bit of a running joke. We use it for all kinds of things, all kind of excuses and justifications for like messy early 20s behavior. And the reason it is so convincing is because I think we kind of feel it. Like we do kind of feel that our reasoning skills improve as we get older. And we certainly sense, we sense ourselves maturing and making better decisions around like our mid to late 20s. So anecdotally, we're kind of like, yeah, I see some evidence for this. I feel like my brain developed at 25. I feel it developing around this time. The other reason why I think that it feels so compelling is because this myth actually did
所以这种额叶在你25岁时定型的想法，我认为有点像个笑话。我们用它来做各种事情，各种借口和理由来解释20多岁时的混乱行为。它之所以如此令人信服，是因为我认为我们确实有这种感觉。就像我们确实感觉到随着年龄的增长，我们的推理能力有所提高。我们当然感觉到自己在20多岁中期到后期变得成熟并做出更好的决定。所以从轶事上讲，我们有点像，是的，我看到了这方面的一些证据。我觉得我的大脑在25岁时发育了。我觉得它在这个时候发育。我认为它感觉如此令人信服的另一个原因是，这个神话实际上确实
originate from some very real scientific research that just ended up being deeply misinterpreted. So people might be able to cite studies for you. Are they reading those studies? Probably not. This idea specifically came from a series of brain imaging research papers that were released in the 1990s and early 2000s. And it also came from the words of one man in particular and what he said. we get to what he said. Let's look at this research. So in the late 1990s, scientists and researchers were trying to answer a very, very serious question, which is, when do people become emotionally responsible for their actions based on brain development? They were, like, specifically, they were trying to look at this in the context of criminality and the death penalty. Is it fair to
源于一些非常真实的科学研究，只是最终被深度误解了。所以人们可能能够为你引用研究。他们在阅读这些研究吗？可能没有。这个想法特别来自20世纪90年代和21世纪初发布的一系列脑成像研究论文。它也来自一个特定人的话以及他所说的话。我们谈谈他说了什么。让我们看看这项研究。所以在20世纪90年代末，科学家和研究人员试图回答一个非常、非常严肃的问题，即人们何时根据大脑发育对自己的行为负有情感责任？他们特别是在犯罪和死刑的背景下研究这个问题。公平吗？
sentence an 18-year-old to death or a 20-year-old, but not someone who was 16 or 17, if their brain development might actually be at an identical, if not very similar level. Like, when should people feel and be responsible for their actions based on brain development? To answer this question, they basically had to know when does the brain fully mature, specifically the frontal lobe, which is the last part of the brain to reach maturity. So starting in 1999, they tracked these. participants and they tracked their brain changes through repeated MRI scans on people when they were children, when they were teenagers, and then when they were adults. This was a longitudinal
判处一个18岁或20岁的人死刑，而不是一个16或17岁的人，如果他们的大脑发育水平实际上可能处于相同甚至非常相似的水平。就像，人们何时应该根据大脑发育感到并对自己的行为负责？为了回答这个问题，他们基本上必须知道大脑何时完全成熟，特别是额叶，它是大脑最后达到成熟的部分。所以从1999年开始，他们追踪这些参与者，并通过对儿童、青少年和成年人的重复MRI扫描来追踪他们的大脑变化。这是一个纵向
study, so they kept the same participants all the way through to see if there was a lot of individual variation, what the kind of standard deviation, the median was. And they discovered that during the teenage years, gray matter goes through a process called pruning. It's a lot like pruning a tree, to be honest, tense probably why they use that word. But early in life, the brain builds an enormous, enormous number of neural connections. We know this is neurogenesis, we spoke about it before. And as we age, it doesn't need all those connections. So it gradually trims back the ones that are not really used, and it strengthens those that remain. And they discovered that more primal regions, like areas responsible for muscle movement,
研究，所以他们一直保留相同的参与者，看看是否有很大的个体差异，标准差、中位数是什么。他们发现，在青少年时期，灰质经历了一个叫做“修剪”的过程。老实说，这很像修剪树木，这可能就是他们使用这个词的原因。但在生命早期，大脑建立了大量、大量的神经连接。我们知道这是神经发生，我们之前谈过。随着年龄的增长，它不需要所有这些连接。所以它逐渐修剪掉那些真正没用的，并加强那些保留下来的。他们发现更原始的区域，比如负责肌肉运动的区域，
for fear, for learning, they develop first, and they're pruned first, whilst more advanced regions that are important for emotional regulation, for decision-making, for social cues and social behaviour, they had not fully matured by the time participants exited the study and had their final brain scan at 20. And this is the crucial thing. The study the big study that said your brain develops at 25, it actually stopped at 20. The oldest participant was 20. There were no brain scans for anyone above that age. So where did we get 25 from? Like, where did this number appear? Well, the man who conducted this research, he obviously did a bit of a press tour around this. He did an interview with Time magazine about five years after the first
负责恐惧、学习的区域，它们先发育，也先被修剪，而对情绪调节、决策、社交线索和社交行为很重要的更高级区域，在参与者退出研究并进行20岁时的最后一次脑部扫描时，还没有完全成熟。这是关键所在。那个说你的大脑在25岁发育的大型研究，实际上在20岁时就停止了。最年长的参与者是20岁。没有超过这个年龄的人的脑部扫描。那么我们从哪里得到25这个数字的呢？就像，这个数字是从哪里出现的？好吧，进行这项研究的人，他显然围绕这个做了一次新闻巡回。他在第一次
study was published. And the researcher asked him, you know, well, in your research, by the end, some of these kids' brains hadn't fully developed and they were 20. So when do you think our brain is fully developed? And he thought about it. And he speculated a little bit and he said, well, you know, if I had to pick a number, I'd probably go with 25. And it was that interview that created this myth that your frontal lobe develops at 25. So what's the truth? The truth is that Neuroscience has evolved considerably since those early studies. And instead of looking at individual regions in isolation or trying to create a general idea, scientists now study how efficiently different parts of the brain communicate with each other across all ages and more specifically
研究发表大约五年后接受了《时代》杂志的采访。研究人员问他，你知道，嗯，在你的研究中，到最后，这些孩子中的一些人的大脑还没有完全发育，他们是20岁。那么你认为我们的大脑什么时候完全发育？他想了想。他推测了一下，他说，嗯，你知道，如果我必须选一个数字，我可能会选25。正是那次采访创造了这个神话，即你的额叶在25岁时发育。那么真相是什么？真相是神经科学自那些早期研究以来已经有了相当大的发展。科学家们现在不再孤立地观察单个区域或试图创造一个普遍的想法，而是研究大脑的不同部分在所有年龄段如何高效地相互沟通，更具体地说
across different periods. It's not like there's a single year. It sees it as kind of these rolling chapters. And a very recent study, it's now quite famous, but it's only conducted in 2025, looked specifically this thing called topological turning points across the human lifespan. This study involves scans from over 4,000 people, from infants to people who were 90, and it wanted to understand, like, how does your brain, how is it wired through white matter across the course of your life? The research has discovered that there are several key periods of development. So the first one lasts until we're about nine, and then the second one is between the ages of nine and 32. And they call this the adolescent period. During adolescence, and I know it
在不同的时期。并不是说有一个单一的年份。它将其视为一种滚动章节。一项非常新的研究，现在相当有名，但它只是在2025年进行的，专门研究了人类寿命中所谓的“拓扑转折点”。这项研究涉及来自4000多人的扫描，从婴儿到90岁的人，它想了解，就像，你的大脑是如何运作的，它是如何通过白质在你的一生中连接的？研究人员发现有几个关键的发展时期。所以第一个时期持续到我们大约9岁，然后第二个时期是在9岁到32岁之间。他们称之为青春期。在青春期，我知道它
sounds strange to think of our 30s or even our 20s as adolescence, but during adolescence, the brain balances two key processes known as segregation and integration. Segregation in a brain sense involves building lots of villages or related thoughts, integration and involves building roads to connect those villages to each other. The research suggests this construction of little villages and the roads that run between them doesn't really stabilize into an adult pattern until about your early 30s. So that brain building, your brain building site is still very much active in your 20s. Now after 32, 30 around that time, the brain starts to really formalize pathways and really build almost like neural fences around different areas.
听起来把我们的30多岁甚至20多岁视为青春期很奇怪，但在青春期，大脑平衡了两个被称为“隔离”和“整合”的关键过程。从大脑意义上讲，隔离涉及建立许多村庄或相关思想，整合涉及建立道路将这些村庄相互连接。研究表明，这种小村庄及其间道路的建设直到你30岁出头才真正稳定成成人模式。所以那种大脑建设，你的大脑建设工地在20多岁时仍然非常活跃。现在在32岁之后，30岁左右的时候，大脑开始真正形式化路径，并真正建立起围绕不同区域的几乎像神经栅栏一样的东西。
And this is when personality and intelligence tend to plateau, not completely, but just plateau. And then the next turning point doesn't really happen until about 66. And it's much milder. And it isn't really defined by as many major structural shifts. And then after that, we have another turning point in our 80s. In other words, your teens and 20s are spent connecting the brain. Your 30s are about settling down and maintaining your most used roots. And up until about 60,
这就是个性和智力趋于平稳的时候，不是完全，只是平稳。然后下一个转折点直到大约66岁才真正发生。而且它温和得多。它并没有真正被那么多的重大结构性转变所定义。然后在那之后，我们在80多岁时有另一个转折点。换句话说，你的十几岁和20多岁是用来连接大脑的。你的30多岁是关于安定下来并维护你最常用的路径。直到大约60岁，
everything kind of seems to operate kind of at the same level. Like we still have neuroplasticity going on. We can still learn, but things kind of settle. But if you are in your 20s and you are worried that the habits you have right now, the person you are right now is rigid, unchangeable, you don't want to be this person, but you're incapable of ever being anything different, that is not correct.
一切似乎都以同样的水平运作。就像我们仍然有神经可塑性在发生。我们仍然可以学习，但事情趋于稳定。但如果你在20多岁，并且你担心你现在的习惯、你现在的这个人是僵化的、不可改变的，你不想成为这个人，但你无法成为任何不同的人，那是不正确的。
There is so much scope for change, and there is so much ability to set yourself up mentally and physically and neurologically for an expansive life. Even in your early 30s, even up until later adulthood, your brain remains flexible. The neural village is always buzzing, always active. Our brain is constantly evolving, constantly shifting, constantly moving to be at its best, which we know from early effects also is what promotes neuroplasticity. So there you go.
改变的空间很大，在心理、生理和神经学上为自己设定一个广阔的生活的能力也很大。即使在你30岁出头，甚至直到成年后期，你的大脑仍然保持灵活。神经村庄总是嗡嗡作响，总是活跃。我们的大脑在不断进化，不断转移，不断移动以达到最佳状态，我们从早期的事实中也知道，这正是促进神经可塑性的原因。所以就是这样。
There is no magical switch. If you are like approaching 25 or just past 25 and you're like, cool, that's it. I've, that chapter is done. No, you are a decades long building project and you have a lot, maybe saying you have a long ways to go isn't like particularly helpful. I think it is. You're not locked in place if you have passed this milestone. And if you are before this milestone, you still have a long way ahead to change your life and change your neural patterns and change your behavioral patterns as well. So this leaves us with one final brain fact for this episode. And you know what? It's not the most glamorous. It's actually not, it's not the most sexy. Maybe it's
没有神奇的开关。如果你像接近25岁或刚过25岁，你就像，酷，就是这样。我，那一章结束了。不，你是一个长达数十年的建设项目，你有很多，也许说你还有很长的路要走并不是特别有帮助。我认为是有帮助的。如果你已经过了这个里程碑，你并没有被锁定在原地。如果你在这个里程碑之前，你仍然有很长的路要走来改变你的生活，改变你的神经模式，也改变你的行为模式。所以这给我们留下了这一集的最后一个大脑事实。你知道吗？它不是最迷人的。它实际上不是，它不是最性感的。也许它
not the most interesting. But I think it's something that I think it's the one we think about the least and we talk about the least as well. And that is the role of forgetting. I know ironic that it's, it's probably the most forgetful, like forgettable brain fact. And it's about forgetting. But your brain needs to forget in order to function. It is not a flaw. It is not a mistake. It is crucial. Until recently, think we thought of forgetfulness or the loss of memories or details as a passive process or a bad process and we didn't want to do that we we didn't want to forget now we know differently there's this man his name is scott small he's the director of the alzheimer's disease research center at columbia university and he wrote this book about five years ago called great title by the way
不是最有趣的。但我认为这是我们想得最少、谈论也最少的事情。那就是遗忘的作用。我知道讽刺的是，它可能是最健忘的，就像可遗忘的大脑事实。它是关于遗忘的。但你的大脑需要遗忘才能运作。这不是缺陷。这不是错误。它是至关重要的。直到最近，我认为我们把健忘或记忆或细节的丢失视为一个被动过程或一个坏过程，我们不想那样做，我们不想遗忘。现在我们知道了不同之处。有个人，他的名字是斯科特·斯莫尔（Scott Small），他是哥伦比亚大学阿尔茨海默病研究中心的主任，他大约五年前写了这本书，标题很棒，顺便说一句
forgetting the benefits of not remembering and in this book the main message was basically that For most people, your ability to not remember what exactly you ate three weeks ago, or even this morning, or that random person's name, your ability to kind of forget about the plot of the movie you saw a couple weeks ago, maybe a year ago, or every unremarkable thing that you've seen is remarkably important and ensures that your brain and you as a person not just survives but flourishes mentally. Studies have shown that there seems to be a specific molecule within our neurons that wants them to forget, wants to clear up space for more important things to come along long term. And basically like this protein, this molecule has like the personality of like Marie Kondo.
《遗忘：不记得的好处》（Forgetting: The Benefits of Not Remembering），在这本书中，主要信息基本上是，对于大多数人来说，你无法记住三周前或今天早上到底吃了什么，或者那个随机人的名字，你能够忘记几周前或一年前看过的电影情节，或者你见过的每一件平淡无奇的事情的能力，是极其重要的，并确保你的大脑和你作为一个人在心理上不仅生存，而且茁壮成长。研究表明，我们的神经元内似乎有一种特定的分子想要它们遗忘，想要为更重要的事情腾出空间。基本上就像这种蛋白质，这种分子有像玛丽·近藤（Marie Kondo）那样的个性。
Like this protein's a bit of a minimalist and it's kind of going through the brain house and being like what's important, what's not, anything that's not completely crucial, let's get rid of it because more stuff is going to be coming through soon. Now this. This molecule is called the mosaishi protein and it's responsible for the structure and the function of our synaptic connections. It's responsible for ensuring that there are clear pathways and that only the most important stuff is communicated. Now this protein has a partner in crime and together I don't even know if partner in crime is the right word, maybe like a bit of an arch nemesis, but they work together kind of they're partially responsible for two parallel mechanisms.
就像这种蛋白质有点极简主义，它在脑子里走来走去，说什么是重要的，什么不是，任何不完全关键的东西，让我们摆脱它，因为很快会有更多的东西进来。现在这个。这个分子被称为“武藏蛋白”（Musashi protein），它负责我们突触连接的结构和功能。它负责确保有清晰的路径，并且只交流最重要的事情。现在这种蛋白质有一个犯罪同伙，在一起我甚至不知道犯罪同伙是否是正确的词，也许像一点死对头，但它们一起工作，它们部分负责两个平行机制。
One of them stimulates the growth of synapses and therefore helps to retain important memories and wants everything to be remembered. And then the musashi protein comes in and actively inhibits the stabilization of these synapses, allowing memories to be lost. And it is the balance between these two proteins, which is so crucial for the retention of memories and some of the most important memories that we have. Our world is buzzing with information. There's so much going on all the time.
其中一个刺激突触的生长，从而有助于保留重要的记忆，并希望一切都被记住。然后武藏蛋白进来并积极抑制这些突触的稳定，允许记忆丢失。正是这两种蛋白质之间的平衡，对于记忆的保留以及我们拥有的一些最重要的记忆至关重要。我们的世界充满了信息。一直发生着太多的事情。
And our brain needs to be able to discard the useless stuff so that our ability to learn and so that our ability to generate new ideas isn't interrupted. And this is really, really crucial. Now, there is also such a thing as not being able to forget enough. Traumatic experiences, conditions like PTSD, make it a lot harder for us as humans to let go of certain memories that feel important because they are painful. And that means that these memories become embedded in our mind, hurt us, impede our ability to recover mentally. PTSD can cause too much emotional memory.
我们的大脑需要能够丢弃无用的东西，这样我们的学习能力和产生新想法的能力就不会中断。这真的、真的至关重要。现在，也有无法遗忘足够多的事情。创伤性经历，像PTSD这样的情况，使我们人类更难放下某些感觉重要的记忆，因为它们是痛苦的。这意味着这些记忆嵌入在我们的脑海中，伤害我们，阻碍我们心理恢复的能力。PTSD会导致过多的情感记忆。
It's kind of like a brain-on-fire disorder, which is also characteristic of other psychiatric conditions, you know, obsessive-compulsive disorder, anxiety disorders, phobias. They have this kind of brain-on-fire mentality where there's just so much information we're trying to remember and sort through and all that feels safe. scary. There was a really interesting paper published in 2024, which was conducted on rats. And in this research, researchers suppressed the production of the protein needed to stabilize memory, and they artificially increased the production of the musashi protein, which is required to forget. And then they put these rats into very traumatic circumstances where they experienced pain
这有点像一种“大脑着火”障碍，这也是其他精神疾病的特征，你知道，强迫症、焦虑症、恐惧症。它们有这种“大脑着火”的心态，有太多的信息我们试图记住和整理，所有这些都感觉安全。可怕。2024年发表了一篇非常有趣的论文，是在老鼠身上进行的。在这项研究中，研究人员抑制了稳定记忆所需的蛋白质的产生，并人为增加了武藏蛋白的产生，这是遗忘所必需的。然后他们把这些老鼠放在非常创伤的环境中，在那里它们经历了疼痛
and they experienced bad things. And they feel. found that those rats who had undergone this intervention to increase forgetfulness, minimize remembering, experienced less PTSD, less long-term fear, and disrupted the formation of traumatic memories. This is such an interesting line of research that is currently ongoing in kind of the trauma space because it basically shows the neural underpinnings of painful memories and why we can't seem to let them go even when we really want to. But it always is, also opens up all these future possibilities for new treatments and new drugs and new methods for helping people properly process really difficult things, you know, in the wake of natural disasters,
并且经历了糟糕的事情。他们发现，那些接受了这种干预以增加遗忘、最小化记忆的老鼠，经历了更少的PTSD，更少的长期恐惧，并破坏了创伤性记忆的形成。这是创伤领域目前正在进行的非常有趣的研究方向，因为它基本上展示了痛苦记忆的神经基础，以及为什么即使我们真的想放下它们，我们也似乎无法放下。但它总是，也为新的治疗方法、新药和帮助人们正确处理非常困难的事情的新方法打开了所有这些未来的可能性，你知道，在自然灾害之后，
in the wake of war or genocide. Not that we want this to go too far, we have to be careful here. I feel like this could be misused very easily, could be capitalized on in many ways, or we could end up with like kind of an eternal sunshine on the spotless mind situation. another great movie, by the way. Actually, probably the first great movie we've mentioned in this episode, but a great movie. But for people who have tried everything, for people who have what we call treatment resistant PTSD or depression, I think these findings offer a bit of a miracle in a way. And there's so much about the brain is miraculous. Like, it's just incredible that we could assist people with forgetting some of the worst times in their life or at least reducing the emotional
在战争或种族灭绝之后。并不是说我们希望这走得太远，我们在这里必须小心。我觉得这很容易被滥用，可以在很多方面被利用，或者我们最终可能会陷入像《美丽心灵的永恒阳光》那样的境地。顺便说一句，另一部伟大的电影。实际上，可能是我们在这一集提到的第一部伟大的电影，但这是一部伟大的电影。但对于尝试过一切的人，对于患有我们所说的治疗抵抗性PTSD或抑郁症的人，我认为这些发现提供了一种奇迹。关于大脑的一切都是奇迹。就像，我们能够帮助人们忘记他们生活中最糟糕的一些时光，或者至少减少它们的情感
intensity of them. And again, there's that word miracle. And I feel like the more you learn about the brain and how everything is kind of constructed and built in this way to protect you and to allow you to have a human experience, it's just honestly mind-blowing. It's so mind-blowing that not even for a second, I think, do most of us think about this on a day-to-day basis? Like, you and I are not tasting food or experiencing heartbreak or forgetting where our keys are and thinking about musashi proteins or synapses or neural priming or whatever. But it's going on and it's keeping us alive and it's doing all these amazing things for us. And if we can use that to our advantage, like, that is incredible.
强度，这真是令人难以置信。再一次，那个词“奇迹”。我觉得你对大脑了解得越多，以及一切是如何以这种方式构建和建造来保护你并允许你拥有人类体验的，这真是令人震惊。这太令人震惊了，我想我们大多数人甚至一秒钟都没有在日常生活中考虑过这一点？就像，你和我不是在品尝食物或经历心碎或忘记钥匙在哪里，而是在思考武藏蛋白或突触或神经启动什么的。但它正在发生，它让我们活着，它正在为我们做所有这些惊人的事情。如果我们能利用这一点为我们所用，那真是太不可思议了。
It also shows how so much of like the supposed flaws in our brain just show an incredible science. Like forgetting is incredible pain and how it relates to all these different parts of your body, to the gut, to the mind, to your pain receptors is incredible. you know, how strong you feel about heartbreak is incredible. The fact that like we can focus is incredible. I feel like I'm just going over and over this, but it all comes down to this incredible science and this incredible, the incredible neural information that your brain stores. And I think there is something incredibly humbling about that. We spend so much of our lives wishing our brains were different, comparing how our brains to how somebody else's brain works,
它也展示了我们大脑中所谓的缺陷是如何展示出令人难以置信的科学的。就像遗忘是令人难以置信的痛苦，以及它如何与你身体的所有这些不同部分、肠道、思维、疼痛感受器相关联，是令人难以置信的。你知道，你对心碎的感觉有多强烈是令人难以置信的。我们能专注的事实是令人难以置信的。我觉得我只是在反复说这些，但这一切都归结为这种令人难以置信的科学和这种令人难以置信的、你的大脑存储的令人难以置信的神经信息。我认为这其中有一些令人难以置信的谦卑之处。我们花了很多时间希望我们的大脑不同，比较我们的大脑与别人的大脑是如何工作的，
thinking they're more smart, they're more creative, they're calmer, they're more resilient. And we don't really stop to appreciate the staggering amount of work that our mind and our brain does every single day just to keep us here and just to keep us alive and functioning, but also our conscious role in that as well. Like you have a bit of a say here. You can influence how your brain is wired and structured through neuroplasticity, through how you speak to yourself, through the information you choose to feed it, and the behaviors you choose to enact.
认为它们更聪明、更具创造力、更冷静、更具韧性。我们并没有真正停下来去欣赏我们的思想和大脑每天为了让我们留在这里、让我们活着并正常运作所做的惊人工作，同时也包括我们在其中所扮演的意识角色。就像你在这里有一点发言权一样。你可以通过神经可塑性、通过你对自己说话的方式、通过你选择喂养它的信息以及你选择采取的行为，来影响你的大脑是如何连接和构建的。
So that is our episode today. That is all of our brain facts. I sincerely hope you enjoyed it. I hope that your brain maybe feels more dense and connected as a result. Hopefully it feels more plastic. Yeah, I just hope you learned something. If you want to keep up to date with new episodes of the podcast, including more science-based episodes like this one,
这就是我们今天的节目。这就是我们所有关于大脑的事实。我真诚地希望你喜欢它。我希望你的大脑可能因此感觉更致密、更紧密。希望它感觉更具可塑性。是的，我只是希望你学到了一些东西。如果你想了解播客的新剧集，包括更多像这样基于科学的剧集，
make sure that you are subscribed or you are following along wherever you are listening, and that you're also following us over on Instagram or substact. because we share so much more psychology and science and research content over there, and we make sure it's all accessible. So if you've ever had any questions about how your mind works, why you feel the way you feel, why you do the things you do, that's a great place to learn. Thank you to our researcher Lucy Davidson for her help with this episode.
请确保你在收听的地方订阅或关注了我们，并且你也在 Instagram 或 Substack 上关注了我们。因为我们在那里分享了更多心理学、科学和研究内容，并且我们确保它们都是易于理解的。所以，如果你曾经对你的思想如何运作、为什么你会有这样的感觉、为什么你会做你所做的事情有任何疑问，那是一个学习的好地方。感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）对本集节目的帮助。
And if you have made it this far, leave a little brain emoji down below if you are listening on Spotify so that I know you've got a great attention span. You made it all the way to the end. Until next time, be safe, be kind. and be gentle to yourself. And look after that brain of yours. We will talk very, very soon.
如果你已经看到了这里，如果你是在 Spotify 上收听，请在下方留下一个大脑表情符号，这样我就知道你的注意力很集中。你一直坚持到了最后。下次见之前，请注意安全，保持友善，并善待自己。照顾好你的大脑。我们很快就会再聊。
Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Each week, we talk to someone in show business and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time, and no one gets mad at their publicists
嘿，我是海耶斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。我是肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们主持播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。每周，我们都会与演艺圈的人交谈，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人会因为他们的公关人员
for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, Adam Scott, Danny McBride, Ben Stiller, and a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle.
让他们参加我们的节目而生气。我们有很多很棒的嘉宾，比如莎拉·谢尔曼（Sarah Sherman）、亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott）、丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）、本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller），以及许多如果没有我们就不可能有今天成就的其他大人物。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个陌生人提议让我搭他的摩托车。
I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pig. for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers,
我选择了选项 B。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以先说“是”，而无需先征求任何人的意见。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代孤独。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Solita》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。《Pro Society》是一个每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、
book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes
图书博主以及大量深思熟虑的观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的点点滴滴联系起来。我着迷了。我着迷了。我着迷了。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Pro Society》。我曾在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的事情中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特（Elizabeth Smart），这是《幸存者档案》（Survivor Files）。每周，我都会与那些经历过不可思议之事的人在一起，他们曾被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。这些故事讲述了需要什么
to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our hometown is not a test tube. 90 miles northeast of Nashville,
才能活着走出来。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。我们的家乡不是试管。在纳什维尔东北 90 英里处，
a battle for the future of America plays out in one small town. Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land. We need cities on a shining hill. This is our town. A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment and fights back. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you?
一场关于美国未来的战斗在一个小镇上演。有右翼背景的开发商购买了数百英亩土地。我们需要山巅之城。这是我们的城镇。一个关于当一个小镇成为社会实验的场所并进行反击时会发生什么的播客。我想你们现在没搬进一群笨蛋乡巴佬中间吧，是吗？
Listen to Our Town on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《我们的城镇》（Our Town）。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证是人类制作。本集节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。